- Cool.
- Let's get that post up ASAP.
- OK.
- Ferg.
(laughs)
I'm gonna start doing that, I think.
I think I just invented something, vlog.
Just every time I say ASAP,
I'm just gonna rap Ferg a little bit,
paused after it because that's my man.
Show some sorta highlight there.
If I could rap I'd be fuckin' rappin',
I would've wrapped it all up by now.
I would've sold all my
businesses, I would be on my way.
- [Mission Controller]
Apollo 11, this is Houston.
You are go for TLI, over.
(slow, steady piano music)
Apollo 11, thank you, roger, out.
(fast, steady piano music)
(techno music)
- [Gary] You made it!
- Yeah, man.
- You figured it out.
Tell me the whole story.
- All right, so I'll
start from the beginning.
Like, I found out about you
through The Breakfast Club.
- Stop watching (bleep) Lost.
- So, like I seen you on there
and was digging what you were sayin'.
Over like, the past, I dunno,
like seven months since I
just like discovered you,
like I feel like sometimes
you're like tuggin' at me,
like while I'm at work
listening to you like,
hey man, quit your job.
- (laughs) Like a voice?
- Yeah, I like my job, but like,
how the heck am I gonna stand out?
And I know you like rap music.
I was like man, if he could hear me spit,
like I know, or at least
I think I can impress you.
♫ It got I got I got I got
♫ Internship on internship
♫ Inside my resume
♫ In that visual communications
♫ I got BFA
- Yeah man, I think we should do it.
I think it's a funny story
for everybody on the internet.
I think, he's clearly got the skills
to be able to do it, and more importantly,
I think we can motivate millions of people
to go and get theirs, too.
I think we owe it to him,
and I think we owe it to
them to make this hire.
I think it'll make the
full circle feel real good.
- 'Grats.
- Okay, thank you.
- Good, you guys go jam.
- That's cool.
- Great.
- Headed to Wine Library now,
do some meetings there with
my own internal media team,
and then head to the Super Tasting
which is a super exciting
charity event at Wine Library.
So it should be a pretty rad day.
(electronic music)
I want to activate every part of,
definitely, as you can imagine,
definitely this, right?
Whole area, people...
There's a lot that can be done.
We have unlimited firepower.
- 'Cause our numbers are pretty high
from a social media perspective.
- You know, it can't be a
bad decision for you guys
to jam with me for (bleep).
Now it's about figuring it out.
- Right.
- Right?
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- I mean, how the fuck can that not work?
- Right, Rick?
- (laughs) Right.
Let me tell you the story of this event.
In 2001, I'd been kind of operating
and been in the game now,
in the business for
about three full years.
And there was a couple of wine tastings
going on in the state.
The laws had changed, and allowed us to do
these kind of events with charity.
Liquor laws are very difficult.
So many laws, can't do a lotta things.
I thought it was our time to
jump into the fray of this.
So I started kind of like strategizing it
in the late spring, summer of 2001.
Brandon Warnecke, who some of you know,
and Bobby Shifrin, my cousin,
who I was just both talking to outside,
who are main cogs in this
business besides me and my dad.
I decided to send them on a
trip to Spain to taste wine,
much to the chagrin of my dad,
who said you can't send the
two most important people
on a trip together.
And I said to my dad,
"You know, it's fine,
"I've got this for a week,
"let them enjoy before the big tasting,"
you know.
As some of you know, I've got high energy,
so not only did I decide to
do our first ever tasting,
this event, then,
but I also decided to
launch our first catalog
even though we were
doing the e-comm thing,
I was doing our first catalog.
So it was a very very very busy
summer and spring that year.
- I just wanna say thank
you for everything,
and I really loved your concept--
- Thank you.
- And I feel I like, changed.
- Thank you so much, ma'am,
really glad you're here.
- Thank you.
- You wanna take a photo?
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
- Thank you.
- It's a real pleasure.
- Hi, I'm Stefan.
Just wanna say thank you so much
for all the stuff that you do.
- Hey, this is Sasha.
Ace.
- I brought a couple of friends.
- I'm glad!
And I'll never forget,
it was actually pretty tough,
even though the business
was growing so quickly
that everybody came back from the summer
and that fall was super busy,
plus the catalog, plus this tasting,
so even for me who can go 24
hours a day and do everything,
I was like, shit, I can't
wait til they get back.
So I'll never forget it.
It was the Jets' first game of the season.
Sunday morning,
it was Herman Edwards'
first game as the coach,
and I was getting ready
to leave the house.
This was back when you
still had a home phone,
and the phone rings just,
I mean literally, I had my
hand on the knob, I'm leaving.
The phone rings, nobody
really calls me at my house,
so I decided to pick it up.
And it's Brandon telling me
that they missed their flight,
that they won't be home,
because Bobby got kidney stones
and he's in the hospital in Paris.
- Have a good one.
You do something with yourself, Babbit?
- [Photograoher] Use your skills.
Can I get the five?
- Yeah, hell yeah!
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- I just started...
- Vlog, look.
We finally found him.
- I'm here.
- We finally found Rick.
- It's Rick and Gary. Love this man.
- Next day was 9/11.
And I get a crazy call from Brandon.
For some of the old-timers in this room,
remember when there was
phones in the planes?
And so he called from the air, Brandon,
at 9:09 in the morning.
And said "great news, we're coming home."
And I said to him,
"I'm not sure, there's
something weird going on."
None of the towers had fallen yet,
but I knew the second plane
had hit, so it was weird.
Anyway, long story short,
they landed in Canada.
They were there for another four days,
they didn't get back
until like September 17th.
(audience laughs)
This tasting was on this day in 9/11,
so I guess five weeks after.
Right around the time
where there was even some
level of conversation
of maybe debating get back to normalcy.
I know a lot of you traveled to be here
but for this area it was hardcore.
And it was just super interesting
because I remember my dad...
It was a very special night
because it helped a lot of people
as one little tiny piece
of getting back to a
fun night and normalcy.
And so this place, this
building, this event
holds a very near and
dear place in my heart.
But what I remember more than anything
was my dad pulling up.
At this point I was really operating.
And he pulled up, and
it was so packed here
and there was so much going on.
And I remember he looked
at me and he goes,
"What other event is going on here?"
And I said to him "No,
this is our entire event."
And he was so pumped, so proud.
And that's just a feeling
I've never forgotten.
- With your dad.
- Yeah, of course.
Want me to take it?
- Sure.
- I got it.
It's a rare photo, dad.
Sasha smiled!
- That's right, that's right!
- He smiled.
Nothing matters to me more than my family
and it's been a lot of fun
getting involved with
Wine Library a little bit.
Mom, you're the most famous person
that's never been on the show.
(Mom laughs)
Give them some good parenting advice.
Something.
Give 'em something.
You've been on the show!
There you go!
You got it, feeling good?
There, you got air time! (laughs)
Mom, give them one piece of advice.
- I dunno.
- Something.
- Just love him the way I love him.
He's my sunshine.
- And, you know, starting
the wine club, which...
How many people, by a show
of hands, in the wine club?
How many not?
Mm-hm.
(laughter)
The honesty is amazing!
It fucking hurt, but it's amazing.
Somebody very interesting,
follow me, come here.
Eric! Eric! Eric!
- What's going on?
- Vlog, this is very important.
- Oh my god.
- This is Eric Godfrey.
Nate, this is Eric Godfrey.
- What's going on?
- This is the man who made
me a New York Jets fan.
This is not a joke.
This man, this man, in my neighborhood,
in the fall of 1982, made me a Jets fan.
Took me to my first
Jets game with his dad.
Like, Eric Godfrey.
- I tried to get my dad to come tonight.
- This is literally...
- So you're my Eric Godfrey?
- I'm your Eric Godfrey,
this is Eric Godfrey.
(laughter)
This is literally the man
responsible for the entire thing.
- When you own it!
- How do you feel about that?
- Fantastic!
I'm glad to be here, man.
This is pretty epic.
- Yeah, it's pretty rad.
- This man I haven't seen.
- Dad!
I feel like tonight's, this,
and hopefully it'll be cool
for you guys to say it one day
if it continues to evolve.
I'm excited to start the
next chapter of this event.
And I really would like to do
this specific event going forward.
You know, I think a lot of you flatter me
with your comments and thoughts,
but nobody dreams bigger for them.
You know, as much as you dream
of me accomplishing my things,
I dream even greater.
And so, even when I sit
in this room in 27 years
as the owner of the New York Jets,
I plan on doing this little event.
And so I'm really really thankful
for you guys to be at
the first one of this.
And I appreciate you guys being here.
So thank you.
(applause)
I'll sit down with you for an hour,
and we'll do a working session.
And I'm thrilled
to give you unbelievable
amounts of feedback on that.
Mainly because I think
I'm really in a position
to give you great feedback,
because I've been thinking
about it for three years.
I've been producing content
every day, filming everything,
with 100% this in mind.
- When the AskGaryVee book came out,
I had my assistant order
a thousand fucking copies
and I was throwing the fucking book.
I was throwing the fucking book.
Told my employee, read it.
(laughter)
Fucking read it motherfuckers!
Because that's--
- So listen, I get it more than you know.
I've been literally building a library
of not only my 2000 answers,
every fucking word out of my mouth.
I believe in it more than anybody.
I think that my legacy and my brand
sits at the top
because I'm Watson.
We both got better
looking as we got older,
which is very rare.
- I'm telling you man, I'm telling you.
- Big night, um, just
a perfect night, right?
It was an event that was a huge thank you
for meaningful charities.
It was a huge night for
me to give back to my dad,
and to my community,
and to the Wine Library
customer community, and staff.
It was a good night.
(soft music)
- [Photographer] Okay, one more?
Oh, lordy.
(laughter)
- I don't think we got it.
Did we get it?
We didn't get it.
We got it?
We got it!